hey I've got Sony's brand-new HTR as our
12 here no one's seen this yet it's a
wired exclusive now coolest thing about
this camcorder is that one it's small
fits right in the on your hand second
coolest thing about it is that it shows
you the full line definition so you get
full 1080p resolution with it very nice
very clear very precise images and the
third thing that we really really really
love about this camcorder is that it has
this really really are cool kickass
image stabilization on it that's only
actually cold from there still camera
technology and what that means that you
can go out drink all night and then in
the morning with your blazing hangover
you can have jitter jitter your hands
and you'll be fine your image nice and
smooth and it won't be Gary at all so
this is the ACRs are 12 and we're going
to have a ton more information about it
the march issue choir
you